une seconde applique trois contre un dans ton dos
tu aurais pu me demander
l'appareil qui contrôle tous les
satellites militaires du monde tombe entre
les mains de quatre gars très dangereux nous avons
besoin de quelqu'un qui peut bouger comme eux se
battre comme eux il est temps d'être  Patriotes,
il n'y a plus de patriotes, juste des rebelles
et des tyrans, alors qui êtes-vous,
je suis xxx Je vais vous présenter votre
équipe au sol d'accord, ça vient de l'
enfant de l'affiche de Red Hills Je ne vais pas demander aux clowns de
surveiller mes arrières à qui feriez-vous confiance
l'extrême
complètement fou
eh bien j'ai ce dont vous avez besoin maintenant c'est l'
équipe avec laquelle je peux travailler ici nous allons
vous rafraîchir vous devez savoir ce que vous faites
là-bas ouais c'est ce qu'elle a
dit Wow ces cas sont le
vrai genre de problème vous  Je n'ai aucune idée de
ce que vous affrontez les
députés recherchent ça va être
court c'est moi tu ne me fais pas le
petit déjeuner dans la vie nous sommes prêts à mourir
pour garder le monde en sécurité et toi je
vis pour ça je suppose que nous  're sur la même
équipe maintenant vous  prêt à m'amuser
j'y vais longtemps j'irai
nous simplifions donner un coup de pied aux puces chercher la
fille et essayer d'avoir l'air dope pourquoi tu
fais
dan ça fait du bien d'être de retour
[Musique]